c'est en montant et ben oui la région
vous savez très bien qu'il
vous savez que vous vous attendiez vous
êtes là j'ai
questionné d'attitude parce que vous
écriviez aux et urbain lui donc voilà je
voudrais un conseil continuez vos nerfs
monsieur parce
qu'aucun enseignant 2022 c'est fini
écoutez moi jeune homme bien élevé
l'ornement techno mais je suis bien
élevé mais je supporte pas le monde
change il ce n'est pas la météo donc
vous ne dites pas que les députés a
soumis n'aime pas
vous avez une gamme à la france les mecs
comme vous je vais crier arrêtez qui est
un petit bourgeois à la maîtrise en
droit de venir insulter les députés
insoumis tourné le dos parce que nathan
grossir
alors ça c'était le clash en plateau
quand vous voyez ça david vous dis toi
c'était arrive de voile à sa rivale dans
la tôle ou en euros et en même temps
qu'aux nantis et non mais je vais vous
dire en plateau même au coulis j'en
connais beaucoup qui sont très sages un
ample atteint existe aussi il y en a qui
sont très sages en plateau et en
coulisses qui sont des salopards dont
cnh alors nous on est honnête voilà
c'est tout maintenant alors justement il
ya eu la situation s'est ensuite
envenimées dans les coulisses juste
après l'émission qu'est ce qui s'est
passé stanislas après l'émission
tout est très simple en effet moi j'en
ai absolument rien à faire sur le
plateau ce soit attendu que ça puisse le
ton puisque le jeu élevé exactement
sérieux cette partie du débat cette
partie aussi du spectacle de la
télévision donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est en sortant
du plateau pour le coup alors que je
parlais avec d'autres invités de
l'émission dont christine kelly et
geoffrey lejeune pour le coup et je
pense que le but n'est pas de faire
toutes les missions dessus parce que le
débat qui arrive ce soir c'est bien sûr
plus important à mon avis mais en
arrivant alexis corbière est arrivé
plein bal grosse modo est visiblement
lui était encore dans l'idée de lever le
ton mais en coulisses a perdu clairement
son sang froid et ses raquel garrido qui
par la suite est arrivé à rajouter son
petit grain de sel en perdant elle aussi
totalement son sang froid et ça pour le
coup je pense à ces nuits du spectacle
c'est juste la coiffe du raquel garrido
et ice cube d'air sur cette séquence
sont totalement pas dû leur sang froid
mais c'est pas la première fois que
garrido ou corbières et parfois après
alors on va voir on va voir la séquence
regarder si aucun souci c'est que c'est
toujours même pas qui a filmé moi
d'ailleurs ah bah c'est toujours pas
vous savez vous adapter à huy âge
eiffage était la drogue il faut me le
dire alors
[Musique]
alors bon c'est vrai que c'est c'est eh
mais c'était plus grave mais en fait en
réalité moi franchement samassa va pas
atteint j'ai très bien dormi le soir
sincèrement parce que je me suis mangé
pas convergé pas beaucoup d'attentes par
rapport à l'histoire des roues et raquel
garrido je ne connais pas je vais pas
amener les revoir dans la vie de tous
les jours en revanche on va juste la
seule question que je pose c'est si des
émaux rist avait fait la même chose le
tolex aurait provoqué le tollé c'est à
dire que là ça aurait été un scandale
etc si si je ne sais pas quel point
d'exploser nous rappeler
quelqu'un de remarcher les fans
fellation à son patron grosso modo ce
serait les ferait un scandale mais
encore une fois moi à titre personnel je
sais que la séquence à buzz et ça m'a
pas empêché de dormir et je le vis très
bien